today with us we have Constantine
kissing from the trigonometry podcast
um so podcast hosting comedian I guess
Constantine is that uh accurate
description as of now uh I haven't done
stand up since the pandemic started uh
so a comedian in retirement or on a
break or whatever it is I I still write
a lot of satirical stuff so I sort of
think of myself more as a satrist but
yeah that's my you're right about my
background podcast The Comedians
Hatteras whatever you want yes and I
think you're based in England right
you're that's not true that sounds
threatening in your accent but yes it's
like I confess guilty yeah I I lived in
London for I guess about 10 years so I'm
I'm familiar with that neck of the world
um but but not because they're not so
Constantine kindly agreed to come on
because I think we talked a while back
about potentially having a discussion
about like areas that we might agree or
disagree Alan and then I listened to
your recent appearance on Joe Rogan and
some of the same issues that I thought
would be useful to discuss came up and
you kindly agreed to and broadly
speaking I would say I don't know how
familiar you are with our podcast but we
we tend to focus on
online gurus or secular gurus so this is
people that fall into the Jordan
Peterson nursing taleb we've also done
Abram candy and uh
who's that guy that we the the science
writer map that we like
not like I was going to say good because
no not Alvarez I gotta say you've got to
treat your guests with a lot of respect
I love it yeah well so
um just just to highlight that we we do
try to range widely across the guru
sphere as it exists but we we do have a
tendency to focus on the kind of IDW
heterodox sphere in part because that's
where a lot of the most dramatic and
bombastic style gurus are the weinsteins
for example but in any in any case one
of the things that we've come across
quite often is that people within the
heterodox sphere tend to see a much
bigger concern emanating from the
mainstream institutions and mainstream
media sources and and have less of a
concern about the the kind of
alternative ecospheres and and Guru
figures that we talk about so I I
thought it might be good to talk about
the relative problems in in each of the
Spheres and where you know you you might
disagree with our emphasis and we might
disagree with yours and so maybe it
would be useful just to start if you
kind of outlined where you're coming
from or where you see your position
being you know in the online discourse
or commentary space or whatever you want
to call it mm-hmm it's a very big and
open question I suppose so the way I the
way I self-identify as a is a kind of
enlightened Centrist uh I don't uh I'm
not interested in partisanship or Party
politics at all in fact I can't really
understand people who are Party
political it boggles my mind it's like
why how you could wed yourself
permanently to one side of the political
Spectrum in
hugely varying circumstances I find
strange that people are willing to do
that
um I uh I'm certainly a fierce critic of
a lot of the mainstream institutions and
the the direction they've taken I I hope
that that hasn't prevented me from being
an equally Fierce critic of where the
old media is going wrong
um and the war in Ukraine and the way
some other supposedly heterodox people
are covering that is something I've been
calling out from the moment that it
started because that is an issue I
understand pretty well being half
Russian half Ukrainian having grown up
in both countries Etc so when I see
people going off the deep end on that
issue I haven't been shy by calling that
out
but yes that's uh I guess that's my
position I I see myself as being
somewhere in the center looking at both
extremes and going you're both crazy
um in terms of the mainstream and the
the alt media uh I mentioned you know
some of the areas where I think the old
media can go wrong I do think you have
to be careful when you're comparing
institutions or systems of communicating
information I'm going to say I'm very
woke here but it's kind of like
stupidity plus power like if a guy on a
YouTube channel with 30 followers are
saying something really stupid I am less
concerned about that than I am about a
mainstream publication saying something
equally stupid because the reach is
bigger and so I do think the mainstream
media which for the moment still has a
much bigger reach and therefore more
influence should be subject to more
scrutiny but apart from that uh I I
don't know if that gives you enough to
start uh sticking pins in me
um yeah so I I know for example that you
had run-ins with
um James Lindsay over Ukraine uh before
his uh ignoble exit from from Twitter
discourse and and I think in general you
have been in the trenches over the
Ukrainian conflict even actually on the
Rogan appearance I I noted that you know
he was more skeptical about the validity
of sending arms to support Ukraine or
American involvement and and you push
back a little which I think is your
credit
um but so I guess from what you said
the value of like being able to
criticize people on on both sides of the
political spectrum and including people
that might agree with you is something
that you would seem to regard as like an
important value right that well Ukraine
is just the latest example so I've been
very clear uh for example that
um even though because of some of the
people that I've interviewed there are a
lot of people that think I'm massively
on the Trump Trend and I have friends
who who are big Trump supporters I'm
good friends with someone used to work
for Donald Trump at a high level but I
am very clear that what I was very clear
on January the 7th on the morning of
January the 7th when appearing on the
Lotus Eaters podcast with Francis uh
that I thought what happened it was a
complete Abomination and completely
wrong to the let's just say
dissatisfaction of many of the people in
his audience
um so I'm I'm not really ever hesitant
to criticize either side when they're
doing something wrong I just see that
the threat from the I don't like the
word work anymore because it was first
it was co-opted and now it's been
recovered and I you know but the threat
from the progressive left
uh particularly in the reaction it will
trigger from the right is to me a far
bigger far bigger concern uh than some
of the other stuff so that's why I've
I've been a vocal critic of that because
I think it's it's very very dangerous
yeah so I I guess one of the points that
I would re is is that whenever I listen
and we listen to a lot of content where
people are being critical about the you
know institutions or or the the kind of
social justice left or Progressive left
or however you want to frame
um and one thing that often seems to go
unmentioned in those conversations is
first of all that there is a very large
receptive audience for critiques of
those mainstream positions and of social
progressivism on the right and those
tend to be not what you're talking about
with like small YouTube channels you
have huge media entities you have
National newspapers and you have like
channels dedicated to pompinoid
right-wing ticks and I I often see that
if it is recognized like just kind of
gestured out that there is right-wing
media but the right wing media is like a
huge ecosystem and in terms of this
information or you know kind of pumping
out partisan rhetoric it seems
equally if not much more guilty than the
left-wing media ecosystems you know if
you're looking at Pride part or the
epoch times or the Fox News there's
there's definitely a very strong
tolerance there for partisan positions
so I wonder in in those terms I rarely
see that like on Joe Rogan that's very
rarely discussed for example and do you
think that is a case of there being just
more of a focus on on the issues of the
left or why why does the right wing
ecosystem tend to get a pass in
heterodox spaces I don't think that it
gets a pass I just think to Liberal
people like me and Joe the idea that Fox
News is full of [ __ ] and is
right-wing propaganda is taken as given
uh I don't I've been on Fox News once I
think I don't consider it to be an
objective source of information just
like I don't consider CNN to be an
objective source of information however
when you talk about the ecosystems being
equal I I wouldn't agree with that I
mean look at so I went on Twitter this
morning and I saw a tweet from Joe Biden
uh talking about how
uh he was basically criticizing the
right but what he was saying is we have
a situation where people uh either uh if
if there's an election either they win
or they believe that the election was
stolen and this is treated as a
perfectly reasonable thing for Joe Biden
to to say even though it's very clear
that the mainstream media spent four
years after the election of Donald Trump
in 2016 lying endlessly about his
election the reasons for his election uh
just claiming it was Russia collusion
Russia interference Russia Russia Russia
Russia Russia to the point where at the
time even I believed it and one of my
reasons for being so disenchanted with
the mainstream is how much they've been
lying to us so but nonetheless Joe Biden
can go out and say that and no one is
going to flag up his tweet for
misinformation in the way that they
would do with someone on the right if
they tweeted something like this
um so I think the idea that there's an
equal and opposite Echo chamber is
untrue I think the number number of
outlets and how seriously they're taken
by the ordinary person it's completely
different if I was to
give an army friend of mine quote
unquote uh an article from Fox News the
way they would treat that would be very
different to to an article from the
guardian even though in my experience
they're both equally frequently equally
as inaccurate as each other and in some
cases Guardian is more inaccurate and
the [ __ ] that they're peddling is
worse and so I think that to present
these as equally significant is
inaccurate in my opinion so in in that
case cousin things like one thing I'd
I'd push back on though I listened to
Rogan's podcast and we've we've covered
them in a couple of episodes and it's
not
accurate to kind of present you was
having just a complete wide variety of
perspectives in terms of political tics
generally speaking he tends to be more
in line in modern terms with the right
wing positions like the the conservative
right I mean the politicians that he is
in favor of our like de Santa Bernie
Sanders
um both Bernie Sanders Joe said that he
would possibly vote for him in the
primary and then when it was presented
as an endorsement he himself clarified
he wasn't endorsing just saying he liked
Bernie but but he had but when he
Saunders on the show and he had Cornell
West on the show who's a radical leftist
Professor I'm not by the way I wouldn't
claim that Joe show is entirely
politically balanced no show can be and
I am not pretending that Joe is a left
Winger I think by the current conception
in the current climate I think he would
be Center to write on most of his
politics although I actually I think I
pissed him off a lot by saying that open
borders is a really stupid idea I heard
him later talking about how maybe it's a
good idea so I don't know what his take
is on that uh but I I don't think
presenting him as conservative is at all
the correct way of presenting his views
yeah I I think that probably Matt and I
have a slightly different perspective
although we would agree with you there
are various issues where you know like
people are complex they have you know
different pigs and Joe has a famous clip
where he took the Reuben the task about
the need for regulation right um and
Candace Owens on on green stuff and
others Joe is someone who seeks the
truth and he's willing to challenge
people when he disagrees
so granted you know no person there are
exceptions but like the a not an
outright calamesses but I think if you
take a look at Joe's content over time
and especially during the covet period
it's heavily leans towards the
right-wing narrative and not not lightly
so because we covered his his episodes
with Robert McCulloch and Peter uh sorry
Peter McCulloch and Robert Malone and
the level of kind of endorsement of
conspiracism around covid it wasn't it
wasn't the light asking questions it was
not too far from Majid nowas and those
Figures were introducing that the
pandemic had been planned by the
authorities that the amount of deaths
were being covered up that people with
bullet wounds that they had were being
counted so doctors could profit that no
doctors were interested in curing the
disease and so on and these were quite
extreme positions and then Joe made the
clear on that that he saw it as his duty
to kind of promote these people that
were being silenced and that to me is
not taking you know I'm just gonna see
both sides and and ask because when Joe
had on figures that were pro-vaccine and
there was much less of them but when he
did have them on it was a grilling of
you know uh taking them to tasks and
that is not what happened with the
people who run the vaccine so I know
that's a specific example but I think
that Joe and the other figures in the
heterodox spheres have a tendency to
retreat to we're just asking questions
and having it the beer when the reality
is more advancing a specific narrative
and often that narrative is on the right
and it's I actually think it's perfectly
fine for that to to be the case but just
it it feels like it should be he
acknowledged more than it is
so I I agree with you on a lot of what
you said and I disagree on some of what
you said so what I agree with you is I
do think when we had the peak of uh
lockdown and vaccine enforcement and
talk about mandates and all of this
stuff I do think during that period the
people that Joe had on and the way that
he talked to them you accurately
describe in that it was more to one side
than the other and the way the guests
from one side were treated was different
to the guests from the other side well I
don't agree with you is first of all I
don't see those issues as being right
versus left at all there were plenty of
people on the left uh who uh were
leaning more in the direction of people
like Robert Malone and Peter McCullough
and many many apolitical people too
um so I I wouldn't see that issue as
right and left even though I agree with
the premise of what you say and I said
at the time by the way that I don't
agree with Robert Malone and whatever
but I'm glad Joe had them on and I'll
tell you why I don't know I I didn't
discuss this with Joe so I don't know
why why he made the choices that he made
but from my perspective the biggest
issue that was happening at the time was
uh the idea that government must censor
people for having these discussions uh
that we must prevent people from having
these conversations and to me that's a
very dangerous idea I don't agree with
this at all and I was relieved that the
most powerful podcasts are in the world
was forcing the government to
essentially take note of the fact that
they don't have that option if that is
what they're trying to pursue so while I
disagreed with some of his guest choices
and I disagreed with the balance you
know I I actually when he said I'd like
to have people from the other side on I
suggested a couple of people to him that
I thought would would put the balance uh
the balance view
um and uh you know like it wasn't like
he sort of like cut me out and and never
talk to me again do you know what I mean
like he's open to hearing people's ideas
um so the main points of disagreement
with you is I don't think it's right
versus left and number two I don't
necessarily see the job of the old media
is as always being balanced uh the job
of the media is to provide balance so
these are very different things so if
the mainstream media refuses to do
something then Joe Rogan or trigonometry
whoever may do that thing and then they
both look unbalanced but what we are
trying to do is say look there's this
other point of view that's not being
represented and I think it's important
and in the case of the pandemic my big
issue was we mustn't force people to
take a vaccine and we mustn't censor
people who have even wacky crazy ideas
about that covered the pandemic or
whatever because at the end of the day
if we want to live in a reliable Society
we've got to be able to have these
conversations openly and so I was
simultaneously not happy that certain
people were being promoted and also
happy that they were not being censored
I know that's a complex position and it
sounds quite difficult but that that
that's the way that I was coming at it
from so uh and I and I think that that
will happen on a lot of issues if you
look at the people we had on
trigonometry during the pandemic I think
we were a lot more sensible about it we
we had one guy on who it was Dr cichara
bhakti uh who I think people would
consider very problematic uh and really
we we it's not like we were endorsing
his point of view we just we wanted to
hear what he had to say for himself
YouTube then banned that video and and
gave us a strike for that
uh based on the rules the way they
updated them at the time our interview
did break the law the rules of YouTube
and we therefore didn't appeal her
because we felt it was a fair thing for
them to take down and after that you
know our own views on the issue evolved
when we had covered we put an episode
out talking about how bad it was for
both me and Francis discussing you know
I've updated views and all of the stuff
um so you know we tried to I certainly
always tried to approach it from a
position of honest inquiry and my
concern with all of the stuff is the
mainstream media we're not doing honest
inquiry they were they became a
propaganda wing of the government a
government which as we now know uh were
were prioritizing Public Health over
truth and I don't believe that a
government should ever do that
so there's a there's a bunch of points
that you made there constantly now I
will say that I saw your episode where
you discussed with David Fuller you know
when he was critical about some of the
ways that you covered kovid and it was
your credit that you had that discussion
with him and and he pushed back quite
forcefully I think um and also the
subsequent discussion that you had with
Brett Weinstein on his podcast that just
personally speaking it was very nice to
hear someone saying that I don't have
the expertise I don't think I should be
commenting on this and you know not
everybody needs to issue their takes on
everything people are not experts on on
every topic so I I acknowledge that you
know you you have had I'm not saying
that your position on this has been
entirely you know like just endorsing
right-wing partisanship or that kind of
thing but some of the bits I'd pushed
back on are when it comes to figures
like Malone and McCulloch and the the
kind of anti-vaccine movement although
traditionally there's been opposition on
the left and right particularly the kind
of uh health and wellness left side of
things and the anti-vaccine movement has
traditionally had a lot of support from
kind of models who link it to autism
because of Andrew Wakefield and that
kind of thing right so but but I would
definitely say in covert era there is a
strong right skew to anti-vaccine
sentiment and that you can see this by
the fact that most of the figures who
you're talking about not getting a
hearing in mainstream media are regular
contributors now to right-wing Media Fox
News or in most cases of the people that
appear in Joe Rogan show Infowars as
well which is like may I may I pause you
just for one second I don't mean to
derail you at all I would agree with you
in terms of the media that that have
these discussions
but that's not who's in my experience
who's watching that uh I know loads of
people in my life who who would come up
to me and go thank you so much for
talking about you know the vaccine
mandates and all of this and when I
speak to them my sense is they're not
political at all and they're certainly
not right or left-wing so I I agree with
you that the right wing media grabbed
that as an issue and promoted it because
it aligns with some of their beliefs I
don't think that's who the audience are
obviously I don't have the empirical
data to be able to prove this to you but
I'm just going based on my own
experience sorry to interrupt no that's
fine and I I would take the point that
there were plenty of people who think
there are valid debates to be had about
school openings or the length of
lockdowns and so on but I I tend to
think that you know I'm not saying there
are no missteps or that there there
aren't cases where there's a skewed
towards the government's position on
like mainstream Media or that kind of
thing but I I do think there was a lot
of debate about those Topics in the
media and like that the media is not
such a fractured ecosystem that it was
not difficult at all to hear in fact if
anything it's more like it was very easy
to hear the contrarian takes on things
and that when it comes to like stuff
like vaccines you know there always has
been a a vocal minority anti-vaccine
movement with Andrew Wakefield RFK okay
Junior these these figures right and
typically they're not given mainstream
media coverage because their position is
not equally well supported and those
figures
are not like for example Brett Weinstein
headlined an event with RFK Jr and Dale
big tree and a whole Cadre of
anti-vaccine figures in the UK so the
linkages between the like modern kind of
critical of covered of covet vaccines is
very tied into the anti-vaccine movement
and you know in the same way that we
don't say we need to give equal hearing
to The Climate Skeptics as the climate
scientists it does feel that you can
create a false equivalence by seeking
out you know the kind of memes in Joe
Rogan's form for example that nine out
of 10 dentists recommend this let's get
that one dentist and and see what he
says right so
what about that yeah I hear you so first
of all I I don't think the equivalency
you're making between vaccines that have
been tried and tested for 30 years and
the current conversation about covered
well not the current conversation the
conversation from around a year ago
are in any way comparable I don't think
they're the same issue at all there's a
big difference between a a set of
vaccines that's been around for decades
and a new vaccine uh whose long-term
consequences we do not by definition no
so that's the first point I'd make the
second point is I don't think it's true
that the contrarian view was represented
in the mainstream media at all for the
first year or so of the pandemic I mean
I remember the press conferences
and Boris Johnson was having where never
a single journalist ever questioned him
about have you done some uh analysis on
how many people lockdowns will kill
right and that is a fundamental input
data set that is necessary to make a
decision if you're making a decision
between two choices to go left or to go
right you need to know what are going to
be the outcomes of the left one and what
are going to be the outcomes of the
right one estimates at least otherwise
you cannot make that decision being
fully informed so I don't agree with you
that it was well represented in the
mainstream media in terms of uh Brett
and all of the stuff the the only issue
I have with the way we're having this
conversation and I'm really enjoying it
is you're kind of getting me to defend
other people a lot uh whereas I'd prefer
that you just attack me and I can speak
for myself uh because uh Brett I can
tell you what I think about Brett I
disagree with Brett's approach to covet
I also am not qualified to agree or
disagree with Brad's approach to covert
but I instinctively do not agree with
the way that he's approached it at the
same time Brett is a very good friend of
mine he is a man I respect tremendously
uh him and Heather are two of the of the
the finest human beings that I've ever
encountered in my life and and fortunate
to have encountered quite a few very
high quality human beings so I believe
in being able to disagree with people
about important issues and and still
appreciate the good qualities but yeah
if if you if you want to have a go at me
personally I I'd probably find that a
lot more interesting and
um easier to to have that conversation
so the uh the there's some interesting
points constantly now and I think the
the point that you raise at the end
about the personal relationships between
people is a good point to to switch to
from the covert issue but I just want to
respond to one or two of the things that
you said because Matt and I have spent
quite a bit of time looking at
anti-vaccine rhetoric and this has been
an interest long before covid there's
there's papers from you know 2012 and
stuff talking about the kind of tropes
that you see in anti-vaccine communities
and I can say with complete confidence
that most of the rhetoric that is in the
covert to be it is exactly the same as
the anti-vaccine rhetoric that you would
see 20 or 30 years ago with the same
arguments about it's not all vaccines
it's these vaccines it's long-term
consequences of triple dose mmorr
vaccines and so on so forth and you're
right that we we cannot know with 100
confidence the long-term consequences of
these specific vaccines yet but billions
of people are being dosed and if there
was a genuine danger and the technology
was very risky there is to be about
those kind of things like the doctors
are not villains wanting to mass murder
people so this would be the greatest
controversy ever right if that in 20
years hundreds of thousands of people
are dying early and so on so the
clinical trials that were conducted were
extensive and they're misrepresented by
the anti-vaccine people but I I know I'm
not asking you to get sorry that isn't
but that is an argument I'm making with
all with all respect uh I was talking
about lockdown if you remember so in
terms of the anti-vaxxing stuff I'm not
saying I thought Andrew Wakefield was
going to be Pro the covert vaccine of
course he wasn't and of course all the
people who are anti-vaxxers before are
going to be against this particular
vaccine I'm not disputing that at all
what I'm saying is that there were a lot
of people like me who were simply saying
is the lockdown
the solution to this problem uh and is
having a second and a third one the
solution to this problem I never got an
answer to that nobody ever ever and I
speak to people in government I speak to
ministers in the British government
occasionally none of them can answer
this question how many people did you
estimate that lockdowns would kill
and if you can't answer that question
how on Earth could you have made the
decision to lock down in the first place
and how on Earth could you have made
that decision to lock down further and
when I'm talking by the way about kill
I'm not talking about the vaccines going
around killing people I'm talking about
we do have a record in excess deaths at
the moment it's not just suicides it's
cancer treatments that end up being
canceled it's whatever it is and it's
going to run for decades the
consequences of these decisions and all
I wanted number one was to have a
transparent conversation about that
number one number two I thought that in
the desire to achieve their Public
Health objectives uh which is to get
everyone vaccinated blah blah blah blah
blah the government attempted in this
country I mean did you don't even get me
started on Canada and Australia and
Germany and Austria but even in Britain
the government went way too far in
attempting to deny people their basic
civil liberties and their rights and
attempting to force people to take a
vaccine against their will I mean I made
this point on Joe Rogan I'll make it
again does it make any sense to anyone
that you've got a health Minister like
Sajid Javid who is not a medical expert
forcing doctors
to have an injection that they don't
want to have yes does that make any
sense it makes sense to you it does okay
explain to me why that makes sense
because the public health procedures are
not just decided willy-nilly and yes I'm
thinking I've heard you in other
contexts talk about how people with
utopian World Views about why you know
the the world can be perfected and if we
just get the right political system but
one that's inaccurate representation of
human nature and it can lead to very bad
places right you could be in World Views
so you have the price in constantly when
you're dealing with government if you're
dealing with public health that there
will be miscommunication there will be
inefficiencies there will be like
miscommunications right sure and and so
when you price that in and my experience
of the pandemic it it does sound very
different to yours because I did see not
only only in mainstream media like
politicians being questioned about
policies but also in podcasts with
virologists who are very strongly
pro-vaccine to be it's about what mind
it's what public health measures are
appropriate and not and and robust
discussions about it and it was
presented as if that was never allowed
but I heard it all over the place and I
heard heterodox people endlessly
complaining Joe Rogan completing every
week about it and the reality is that
you won't forced to get vaccines right
unless you were working in health
services or education or or government
but
yeah right right but the reason for that
is to avoid vulnerable populations being
impacted so there is a public health
rationale for it and individual doctors
saying well I don't want to do that that
is their right to do so but you can't
say that if you have a regulation where
like if a doctor says you know I don't
believe that I need to clean my hands in
order to stop viruses spreading and he's
medically trained you don't say well you
know he's got reasons for things how
many doctors are doing that though well
yeah but no no no no but this is the
point this is exactly the point because
it wasn't
0.01 of doctors saying I don't want to
have this vaccine it was quite a lot of
them and we were going to lose a lot of
medical stuff when my son was born four
and a half months ago several of the
nurses who or The Midwives of rather who
who helped to deliver him in private
told me that they were not vaccinated
and that they were going to leave the
National Health Service if they were
forced to do it so I'm not just talking
based on just you know something I
invented in my head I'm telling you
there were lots and lots of people who
were medically qualified who did not
want anything to do with this vaccine
now why they did or didn't is a
different issue my point to you is that
in a situation where a significant
minority of doctors and medical experts
don't want to have a vaccine I don't
think it it makes any sense for that to
be enforced upon them particularly when
we don't have any evidence that the
vaccine was hugely effective at
preventing transmission from one person
to another yeah but the vaccine has
proved extremely like when we're talking
about the impacts of covert right you
know the death statistics and stuff make
it very clear that this did lead to
access devs across the world a large
impact on public health services and
medical facilities and transmission the
way that it's often presented in I find
in the heterodox sphere is as if the
vaccines are you know practically
useless and do nothing but when you look
at them I don't think that at all
yeah I'm not saying I'm not saying you
specifically Constantine but I mean that
transmission relatively less effective
with leader strains right with the
earlier vaccines but in most cases not
on a part just less effective and when
it comes to stopping the spread amongst
the population of the virus Public
Health has to take something of a
one-size-fits-all approach I mean you
I'm sure you think that but I disagree
with this completely I mean this
argument can be used to push all sorts
of tyranny onto the population because
if the interest hold on a second let me
answer your point if the interests of
the great of the nation require some
sort of Health measure
I mean you know we've got to protect the
NHS why don't we just shoot obese people
they are the real epidemic they're the
ones that are doing it how far do you
take restrictions of people's civil
liberties and forcing people to inject
stuff in their body why don't we invent
a vaccine for obesity and force fat
people to take it almost everybody in
our society would completely agree that
that would be unethical forcing people
to have an injection that they don't
want to have would be considered
unethical in any other circumstance
other than when everyone sheds the bed
over covet so how about childhood
vaccination for things like polio and
tuberculosis which are optional I'm in
favor of it and I want my son to have
why why but why is I think those
vaccines would be advantageous to him
but if they are not mandated like
childhood vaccination and you choose not
to have it for your kid and the polio
virus comes back or your child gets
polio and is badly injured so your
preference would be that we don't mind
the any vaccinations for any diseases
and allow them to return or is it
specifically covered I think it's
slightly different with children because
children are incapable of making that
decision for themselves we're talking
about adults so if we're talking about
adults in the context of covert but I
don't think covert vaccines should ever
be mandated now but just covid vaccine
so you do think there are circumstances
where if the disease is infectious
enough or debilitating enough that it
could be right to mandated in order to
keep immunity in the protection I think
for me the issue is is less about the
disease although obviously that's a
factor I don't give people stupid to
pretend otherwise if Ebola had the the
levels of spread of covid we'd be having
a different conversation although I
don't think you'd need to force a lot of
people to take it because they'd be
taken it themselves but it's for me the
issue is children children you know they
have to have adults make decisions for
them and that's a bit different so that
that would be the difference for me but
my point is is something else which is
the the the the taking away of people
all sorts of peop rights that people
normally have during covert that was the
thing that annoyed me and those were the
rule the principles that I thought were
being violated that I thought were
important to stand up for which is why
again I encourage you to ask me about my
views as opposed to defending people who
think the vaccine is you know a 5G plot
or whatever the hell that is
sure so that leads maybe we can leave
you know the the vaccines behind I know
it's a topic that endlessly becomes a
sinkhole for conversation and and I
appreciate you responding about it as
you have but the point that you raised
before that Constantine was you know
that like for example with Brett you
might disagree with his views if I
covered and you're not responsible for
his particular views and that you find
him to be a very you know nice person
principled person and and his wife
Heller as well and that that raises to
me something which I hear a lot of in
again I'm going to use the the term like
the heterodox Spears or whatever but
there seems to be an over Reliance on
this heuristic if somebody is
interpersonally nice to you that that
this is somehow indicative that they
can't actually be promoting
misinformation or actually being hold on
hold on hold on hold on second the very
first thing I said is that I don't agree
with Brett about covert okay so let me
let me finish what I uh the point I want
to meet there because it's I'm not
saying that that is sorry I I mean more
in line with like in most occasions I
don't find it hard to imagine that
people are able to have positive
interactions with someone so recently
with your appearance with Rogan you
talked about meeting Sebastian Gorka and
him being a fun guy to hang out with to
go to your shooting Ridge to eat steak
or whatever the case might be and I I
find that to be like when it's presented
as a novel Insight or something that we
need to bear in mind it strikes me as
potentially rather than insightful and
interesting to be obfuscating of the
reason that that person's criticized
because usually the reason is not that
you know they are a fun person to have
dinner with it's because of the
particular ideology or information that
they're promoting that they get the
criticism and I see constant kind of
refrain to personal relationships and
the importance of them as if that is
something that we we aren't considering
enough and that if I mean if you could
sit down I know this is gonna I'm just
I'm using an extreme example I'm not
saying Sebastian Corker it says but I
mean if you could sit down and have a
nice dinner with Victor Orban and you
know he can have a nice chat with you
about the problems of work culture it
doesn't mean there's any less repression
of the media or authoritarian steps to
control opposition parties in Hungary
and yet you have lots of people who are
reeling against authoritarianism and the
work and going to Hungary right have I
done that again you're you're talking to
me about other people I am not a fan of
Victor Alban have never defended him but
have never commented about him not least
because I don't know anything about
Hungarian politics but let me come back
to your point about what I said about
Seb Gorka
you're doing a disservice to what I said
because I didn't make the point that Sab
Gorka uh is a good guy and I went for
stake and shooting guns with him and
therefore blah blah blah blah blah what
I said is not only that we had dinner
with him and some of his conservative
friends and what I said was these are
people who love this country they care
about this country they're actually well
intentioned even if you may disagree
with the way that they behave right and
that is my point my point is twofold
first of all we have to get back to the
idea that we can disagree with people
without hating them
and I do think that is something that
we've lost a lot with the emergence of
social media would anyone disagree with
that number one number two when you talk
to people whose Behavior you sometimes
don't approve or don't like you may
often find out things about them so for
example
Seb gave me a copy of his book and I
read the first few pages on the plane as
he gave them to me and he talks about
how both his daughter and his son
were being
I think one of the newspapers called his
son his 17 year old son a traitor in a
national newspaper headline and his
daughter was nearly kicked out of her
University for quote unquote being
racist for being his daughter and for
being his son now do you think it's
possible that the version of Seb Gorka
you see on CNN defending president Trump
after he's constantly lied about for
four years and his children are being
attacked do you think it's possible that
the angry version of him that you see on
TV has something to do with those things
as opposed to to do with what kind of
person he is because my four and a half
a month son is next door and I can tell
you if someone was going after him in a
national newspaper because he's my son I
would go [ __ ] ballistic right so in
some ways the way that said behaves
sometimes is quite restrained given the
experiences he's been through and I I'm
not saying that justifies his behavior
I'm not saying I agree with everything
he says I don't support Donald Trump in
the way that he does however I do think
that is important context that gets lost
when we have these debates in this clip
clip clip this is the worst of the Seb
Gorka ever kind of way and that was the
point that I was making it wasn't that
the fact that I had stake with him means
that he's a good guy
I think I'd pushed back that I sincerely
died one I would not automatically
accept the way that Gorka would present
how he's been treated or the it may be
the case that he's had you know harsh
media coverage and his family have been
targeted but I died that before those
events that he was very mild-mannered
Soul who was not a plemicist I think
that there's a a culture of victimhood
on the right which is is quite ironic
because there's a constant complaining
about it on the left you you yourself
Constantine have mentioned in lots of
the discussions that you've had with
with people that you know we shouldn't
spend so much time feeling sorry for
ourselves because things are pretty good
for us we've got big audiences and
people listen to us and we have nice
conversations right and then I I
completely agree with that position but
I I guess the point one of the things
that you emphasize at the starter
conversation was the importance of being
able to criticize both sides and people
on that you you broadly agree with in
some ways that's often more important
than being able to attack the people on
the other side of the political aisle
and and that's part of why I am raising
these examples like people traveling in
Hungary to Urban or the you know the
anti-vaccine stances because what I see
for example is that when people in the
heterodox view get together they're
often fine to talk about their
Collective enemies the the progressives
and the welcome what they're doing wrong
and they avoid those topics which might
be what have I avoided this is this is a
problem when when you talk about
Hungaria you talk about what am I about
so for example Constantine would you if
you had Peter progression on are you
likely to hold his feet to the fire
about why he's in Hungary doing tours
for orban's government when you've spoke
with Douglas Murray Have You Ever Raised
the issue of his defenses of right-wing
populist leaders across the world
because I don't think his support for
right-wing populist leaders around the
world needs defending uh I don't know
anything about Peter pagassian stores I
like I said I know anything about
Hungarian politics if I did I wouldn't
hesitate to ask him about it at all no
but in isn't there something where you
can basically take that stance because
you know you can prepare for interviews
right then you can check what stances
people have taken on things and if you
choose to go with that like let's say
you had James Lindsay on right and you
and many people have and discuss with
him the issues of the social justice
left his kind of me and focus but the we
astutely do not discuss his conspiracy
again you're talking about other people
I had James Lindsay on my show with
Peter uh three years ago at which point
we talked about the things that were
interesting to us at the time we haven't
had James Lindsay on on the show since
and one of the reasons is his Twitter
Behavior Uh to me makes him completely
discredited person uh and so the if we
wanted to have him on and talk about his
Twitter Behavior we'd happily do that
the problem is a bunch of people have
already done that with him he has his
[ __ ] excuse which is Twitter doesn't
matter uh that you know what what do you
want me to do with that get them on for
an hour and and talk about that there's
no benefit to that I said what I said
about James both publicly and privately
I think I chose my words uh very
carefully and uh described what I think
he's become so my problem with this
conversation I'm really Keen for us to
to have the robust discussion is you
keep presenting other people as being
somehow contaminating of me when I'm I'm
not connected I'm not doing those things
it's not it's not about contamination
it's about willingness The Challenge and
and more if people are going to tell me
where am I where am I not challenging
people that I should be okay so an
example you interviewed Brad and Heller
about the book The Hunter galleries
Guide to the 21st century yeah this was
at the height of their promotion of
anti-vaccine rhetoric sure you didn't
raise it at all and other people have
noted that when they were arranging
interviews with them the publicist asked
them not to address that controversy you
got a lot of criticism from your
audience that I saw at the time for not
raising that issue Michael Schumer did
the same thing so that's a case where it
looked a lot like you were avoiding a
controversial issue to talk with someone
about their position that's a specific
issue that's that's not accurate because
what happened is we had Brett on like a
couple of months prior and so to talk
about the curved stuff again would have
been completely pointless I think that
publicist did say they wanted to talk
about the book I was much more
interested in the book than talking
about covert that's why we didn't talk
about covert so but I I don't see that
as shying away from challenging people
on difficult things it's just we wanted
to have a conversation about a different
issue at the time and as you saw in my
conversation on Brett's podcast I had
absolutely no problem saying what my
opinion was about the issue of code and
what my disagreements are with him so
it's not an unwillingness to challenge
it was just an individual instance in
which that was how it was again if
you've got other issues where you think
I'm not challenging someone I'm open to
hear it okay so another example then
because you know that's like specific to
the the podcast so when you talk about
enlightened centrism and an approach
which is a political the advertisements
on your podcast for example are for
Nigel farage's cryptocurrency and uh no
no no no no no it's not cryptocurrency
sorry no it's for an investment company
that he founded 30 years ago that gives
people investment advice it's not a
cryptocurrency okay so so Nigel farage
is uh no no it's not Nigel farage's it's
an investment advice company that
happens to have been founded by Nigel
farage I'm not selling it as you love
Nigel farage therefore buy this thing
it's useful information for people who
want to make investment decisions okay
but we do not so you've I think The
Branding involving Nigel farage is
incidental to that suggested by the
people that's what they wanted right
right we that we we advertise people who
give us money
so but that would be my question to you
then so okay the epoch times for example
yes is a far right publication by most
metrics that has promoted like
anti-vaccine the big lie it's it's
promote Journal uh conspiracies and it's
associated with the falun gong movement
and it is not hard to look at critiques
of it nice when you have advertised for
it it's quite a ringing endorsement and
the point I want to make there is
if the majority of advertisers for you
are leaning in that particular you have
no evidence to make that claim
whatsoever you've picked out two
examples and called that the majority we
advertise hundreds of different
businesses every year would your
contention be that those are
unrepresented my contention would be
that the overwhelming percentage I'm
talking 90 plus percent of our
advertisers are apolitical in any way
shape or form
so in in that case Constantine if a far
left organization wanted to promote on
your show would you also read an
endorsement what depends on it depends
on what it was I'd have to say I don't
know what you mean by far left first of
all we've had people who I consider to
be uh you know weird lefties of the kind
that I massively disagree with who are
currently peddling to Ukraine Nazis
[ __ ] and whatever people like Aaron
matte and Jimmy dorem whatever and if
Jimmy Dore wanted to advertise his
YouTube channel on our Channel I'd say
you know we'd have to have an internal
conversation about that it's
um so but also
I don't know that your your
characterization of epoch times as far
right is accurate that's certainly not
been my impression when I've read it so
I don't accept that either I don't think
Nigel farage is far right by any stretch
of the imagination uh so again he out of
you kept yeah ukip were not far right
Nigel farage is a thatcherite
economically and he was pro-brexit
where's far right in that what what's
well for example like during the brexit
campaign the poster that they produced
with the large
crowds of people colored people
anti-immigration sentiment uh I don't
think wanting to restrict immigration
makes you far right how about the
implication that turkey was on the
process of joining the EU and there
would be millions of Muslims entering
the UK with visas because that that was
likely to politicians like to embellish
their case all the time uh I didn't
think that was a good look but I don't
think it makes him far right
it's a so what is far right that's kind
of neon Neo-Nazi yeah yeah or or someone
who's openly fascist that's what far
right actually means remember these
words have meanings
so they have meanings so you would say
for example the left-wing media has been
spreading all this stuff calling these
people far right doesn't make them far
right these words have meanings my my
ancestors were killed by far right
people right so I'm kind of picky about
these things it's important
certainly so like Stephen Miller for
example in the Trump Administration you
would regard him as moderate
conservative I've never met him I have
no idea who he is uh I've never don't
think interacted with him
but then and so you suggested constant
thing that like you know you wouldn't
advertise something without an internal
discussion and from your reading of the
epoch times it's not far right it's you
know it's maybe conservative tinged or
that but yes I mean in your political
Spectrum so things like the big lie
promoting that is is simply a a moderate
position nine what's the big lie
the big lie is that the election was
stolen by fraudulent voting behavior no
and to me that's an extreme position
that I disagree with very strongly as I
disagree with the spreading the big lie
about the 2016 election which the
mainstream media comfortably spread for
four years with absolutely no criticism
I imagine from people like you as well
well so the distinction there would be
that while there's plenty that you can
criticize about for example ritual
models Precision if people came into
Russia completely decided the election
for Trump I would agree that's not true
but equally the notion that there was no
interference from Russia in leaking the
emails from the Democratic party or or
arranging various online campaigns right
to support Trump those have been
documented quite extensively to actually
have a code under every step along the
way deny deny denied yeah
who peddled a big like and give you lots
of lots of little bits that in their
mind add up to influencing an election
the definitive answer on 2016 is Russian
involvement did not decide that election
you're not being fed to these two
different sides I think they're both
completely wrong and both deeply unfair
and both shouldn't have been done what
you are doing is you're downplay the
behavior downplaying the behavior on one
side and playing up the behavior of the
other side to make it look and balanced
to me there were two big lies and one
was peddled by every major institution
in America and around the world the
other one was condemned by the very same
institutions that spent four years
peddling the first big life it's surely
an important difference is that the
Democratic candidate conceded on the
night and the party acknowledged the
transfer of power and and also to speak
back to your point that I would
automatically defend a claim that the
left wing would make so in the brexit
campaign when people claim the Cambridge
analytica persuade the election by
targeted psychographics I wrote two
articles explaining why that was very
likely not the case and the brexit vote
was just won by you know standard
political campaigning and and I would
say playing up xenophobic sentiment but
in in any case you didn't need the
psychographic explanation it's it's just
you know there was an anti-institution
sentiment and dissatisfaction with the
EU so that's what you get but I think
that that speaks kind to to the point
that I wouldn't be willing to criticize
that but I definitely did not think
there's an equivalence between the Trump
and the Republican Party the mainstream
Republican party stance on the
fraudulent nature of the election and
how many are willing to now endorse that
stance versus the accusation that the
Russians were responsible for the
election because I don't think that is
the same level of support so let me take
back the allegation that you might be
unfair about it because it's unfair I
don't know we were talking about media
coverage we would you started this
conversation by talking about the epoch
times I don't see how it it's any
different for the epoch times to suggest
that the 2020 election was stolen after
left-wing media spent four years
suggesting that the 2016 election was
stolen now the behavior of trump and his
supporters I've already told you my
position on January the 6th but that's
separate to the issue of media buyers
and so if the center right and the
center left both want to lie about
elections I disagree with that very
strongly which is why I immediately
said that this [ __ ] about the
election being stolen you know shouldn't
get all this attention but I I'm just
not comfortable with all this Pearl
clutching about the epoch times when CNN
are perfectly allowed and have and did
for a long time uh not only lied lied
lied lied lied but also then in 2020
participated in what was effectively an
attempt to steal the 2020 election
together with the big tech companies by
suppressing information about the hunter
Biden laptop right that was an attempt
to influence that election and we know
from polling afterwards the Democratic
voters the people who voted for the
Democrats some of them would not have
voted for the Democrats for Joe Biden
had they known about it right so all I'm
saying is I'm not comfortable with all
this Pearl clutching yes the epoch times
is right of Center I don't think it's
far right by any stretch of the
imagination at least in my opinion do I
agree with everything the epoch times
published God no do I agree with
anything any publication Publishers
Garden know do I agree with everything
guests sound trigonometry God no but I
do think we need a media ecosystem where
people are allowed to express their
opinions
yeah I'm fine I think I completely agree
that you know there's there's a broad
church for different opinions and
political stripes and I would actually
argue that there is a lot of space in
the media record system for for whole
reinterviews to me The Epic Times is
quite clearly farther right than
Breitbart which I think that most people
would recognize as being on the farther
right of the spectrum but we'll have to
look more into it I haven't read
everything on the epoch times uh my main
contact with it is a guy called
yannickellick who hosts a program called
American thought leaders which uh uh you
know again some people I agree with that
he has on some people I don't but my
experience of him has been that he's
very honest and very principled
um so I can look into her more that
certainly hasn't been my impression from
a cursory look at it yeah and I will say
Constantine I'm I'm using the example
purely because you asked me to speak
yeah no no no no no no no I'm like I
said I'm very very very happy for for
you to challenge me so let's just come
back to the point though right we
started this conversation with you
saying that the majority of our
advertisers are right-wing or far right
or whatever I think we can agree that
the majority of our advertisers are not
right the majority of our advertisers
are apolitical Nigel farage's Investment
Company not Nigel farage you've got to
understand this right we're not
advertising Nigel farage right although
we've had Nigel on the show a couple of
times I have absolutely no problem with
with Nigel farage I don't agree with
some of the things he said and the last
time we had on I challenged him very
strongly not least on Ukraine yet again
right so it's not like I'm unwilling to
challenge him but we weren't advertising
him in terms of the epoch times you know
we we've talked about that that's one
example I don't think it's fair to
deduce from one example that our
advertising strategy is aimed at people
on the far right or even on the right
frankly
I'll definitely consider I haven't done
you know an inventory of your
advertisements this was just take my
word
yeah it was on the Sam Harris episode
yeah like you know there was quite a
jarring yes the conversation with Sam to
the epoch times so that's what it was
that made it stick up my mind but in any
case Constantine I know that you had a
heart out and you have a young infant I
can do another I don't know I can do
another I'm guessing another five
minutes if you want and then I'm really
gonna have to run if you want okay yeah
that's that's great I I just didn't want
to uh no no no I really appreciate you
being respectful but I I'm enjoying this
conversation so much I'm gonna move
something and uh we'll we'll do another
five minutes go for it okay so uh now my
brain wasn't
you've been extremely quiet I feel bad
if I don't at least give you the option
if you wanted to chime in oh no I was by
the way because just stay quiet so you
guys would have room to talk in the time
that you had uh no sorry my brain was
heading towards wrapping up as well so I
wasn't I wasn't preparing something okay
there was one last thing I wanted to
bring up and I I wanted to see if this
was your position or I'm presenting it
on failure and it's a bit different from
the things that we've been talking about
so I'll try to do it quickly so I
listened to your conversation with the
ex-police officer talking about the
overreach you know the police visiting
people
yes yes uh about tweets and Facebook
posts and that kind of thing right and I
actually would agree with a lot of the
points made about potential overreach
from the police and those kind of
circumstances and how the balance
between freedom of speech and the
policing of offensive like hate speech
right there is clearly trade-offs there
um and the one thing that did strike me
in that conversation was though that
there was this concern expressed about
graduates being preferred for the police
and there was there seemed to be a
consensus and I I included you in this
and if I did it unfairly please correct
me but that the view was the police
force is hiring graduates because they
want people who are kind of drenched in
both ideology that will make it so that
they can promote a progressive agenda
did I say that that was I mean so I
think Harry was it with the name of the
guy that said that Harry
he talked about this primarily but
yourself and Francis seemed to agree
with this assessment that like the
emphasis on hiring graduates was likely
to be because they wanted to instill a
particular ideology and I got the
impression that in general you viewed it
as graduates being sought was an
indication that an institution was
likely to be captured so is that not a
fair representation I'd have to go back
and see what I said I certainly I'm not
conspiratorily minded so I don't think
that they're do they're getting in
graduates because graduates are woke and
they want to workify the police that's
not really my opinion no okay that's
good that's good that was part of what I
wanted to check because and I guess that
would be the kind of thing where I would
say in my case and obviously I'm
argumentative and I have my little bug
bears but I would tend to want to push
back when somebody
introduces this notion of like a grand
conspiracy to you know vocify the world
in order to introduce chinese-style
communism and I know that you are
concerned about the far left and it's
it's blase nature to the threats of the
far left but I I wasn't sure if you find
those conspiracies like the focus on the
Waf and Klaus shrub to be equally
concerning or if you agreed with them I
I just wasn't clear I don't know I don't
agree with them uh as you can probably
tell from the conversations we've had on
trigonometry have you ever heard anyone
uh invited on to talk endlessly about
the WF I think one guest mentioned it in
uh the last question we always ask which
is a complete free hit and generally we
don't tend to debate that when we just
sort of left as a free hit for them
um with what Harry said I you know I I'd
have to go back and see what I said or
didn't say but it's not my view that
there's a conspiracy to infiltrate the
police with with graduates that does not
mean that I don't think that the College
of policing for example wouldn't quite
like to have as many graduates as
possible because it makes their job
easier which is enforcing their
particular views right I mean the way
that conversation might be is we've got
to get the right people in quote unquote
right and that is people with the right
mindset who are able to take the police
into the 21st century that may be the
way that that conversation is being had
and it doesn't seem to me conspiratorial
to think that that might be possible
um but no I'm not really on board with
with most of that stuff I don't find it
particularly persuasive and uh I just
the more I learn about the world and the
more I interact with people who are
actually in government or actually at
the head of the police are actually
doing stuff or whatever the more I
realize how Bloody difficult it is to
get anything done and so the idea that a
few people in the room are going to get
together and and have this sort of
conspiracy seems to me just you know
impractical if actually inaccurate I
mean I look at trigonometry we have in
addition to the three of us Francis
myself and our producer we have seven
staff like I can't we can't get an
episode to go out on time the way I want
like the idea that there's you know
people maybe maybe they're that much
better at conspiring than than we are
but yeah I'm I'm not I'm not I enjoy a
good like I'll happily go and listen to
David Ike for entertainment but I don't
believe it no
yeah so that that maybe that's an
interesting point to round off on that I
I find that there is a there's a
spectrum of concern right and and there
is sometimes the presentation of all our
institutions are captured science is no
longer trustworthy governments are just
purely getting ready to make everybody
eat bugs and live in pods right and and
to be that veers distinctly towards
Hyperbole and and kind of
catastrophizing in the way that Jonathan
height would and I kind of see I again I
I know you're not gonna like me doing
this constantly but I I tend to see
monster ahead of dogs I'm not
necessarily saying you a a greater
concern about the Hyperbole and
catastrophizing of the world I agree
left I agree completely and I I I guess
I I have noticed in your content a note
of optimism that you you think there is
a greater tolerance for different
opinions in my margin and there is a
kind of pushback for different
perspectives so I might be giving you an
undo note of optimism but I've noticed
when people are saying everything is
going to [ __ ] that you do on occasion
push back and say well you know we are
having this conversation and that kind
of thing so yeah I I'm gonna do a lot
more of that going forward too I'm gonna
do a lot more of that going forward
because I think it's important we're
we're shaping the culture by the
conversations that that we have uh
influencing it and I think the Doomsday
scenarios from both left and right are
completely unhelpful and actually very
arrogant in some ways there's a sort of
hubris to this idea that we are the
first generation of people who can't
solve their own problems actually I
think we can
that's a that's a positive note at the
end on and we often criticize the people
that we listen to for undue and lengthy
backpacking about the conversations that
they've had and how great it is that
they're able to do these things but I I
genuinely do appreciate you coming on
and and having the discussion robust as
as it was and uh yeah so if you want to
tell people where they can find you if
they want to hear more of that kind of
thing please do I'm not very good at
doing that
I really appreciate it first of all I
really enjoyed this it was a lot of fun
I'm glad we had it I can be very
passionate particularly when I'm
defending things that I believe in or
defending myself or whatever but I hope
no one confuses my passion with a lack
of respect or a lack of enjoyment this
is exactly the sort of stuff that I love
doing so first of all thank you people
can buy my book it's called an
immigrants love letter to the West it's
a Sunday Times bestseller uh they can
find my podcast which is trigonometry on
YouTube and on all the podcast apps and
I'm on Twitter and sub stack which is
where I put a lot of more substantive
pieces out at the moment uh people can
find me there as well my name is
Constantin kitchen and thanks for having
me
cheers Constantine and that was very
professionally done it was that's how
that's how you do it when you're good at
those kind of things so cheers for for
coming on and yeah well
that was that that's that was our
interview how was that uh it was good um
I'm now casting my mind back to the
Ghost of Christmas Past
um remembering how the power went out I
listened to almost all of it enjoyed it
I've let you both argued your corner
pretty well and then what did I do
afterwards I probably probably had a
drink I'd drink well I I'll definitely
say one thing to Constantine's credit is
that you know you can take whatever
position you like about the arguments
that myself and he made in the preceding
interview but he did listen to the
argument that I made and then allow me
time to respond in full which I just
said that was nice that's nice to deal
with that's what you want he was
responsive to points and he did engage
in turn taking so full marks to concert
17 as a podcast guest for that and Andy
Andy also you know robust exchange he
wasn't walking away in the strap at the
end and that kind of thing so yeah
that's that's also to his credit that's
right 10 out of 10 for interlocutory
skills you too you did well as well um
thank you
[Music]